I couldn't give less of a about
diversity I don't think it's important I
am a first generation dark- skinned
immigrant in the UK I don't want to be
given a leg up I don't want to be given
a hand up I don't need to be a victim I
want the opportunity to compete on Merit
the thing that I really rail against is
when it starts to get introduced into
things where it undermines the quality
of the effectiveness or the output of
that particular thing so I don't need a
diverse Army I want an army that's good
at killing the enemy that's what I want
and wherever you look the introduction
of these arbitrary artificial targets to
me often undermines the quality of the
end product which I I'm against